there's this amazing picture of my
co-worker it's him reading a ninja
turtles book lying next to a super
soaker
when the super soaker came out it was a
game changer the slogan wetter is better
was essentially a mantra for kids during
summer break
so when i went to atlanta to interview
the guy responsible for all that i had
to show him the photo
that's funny
lonnie johnson invented the super soaker
back in 1982
but that is not his only invention
well i have over 100 patents
everything from the nerf gun to a
thermoelectric energy converter he also
worked on nasa's galileo mission to
jupiter and alongside the us military
the first super soaker actually i made
in my shop in my basement in the
evenings when i would come home from
work and at the time i was actually
working on the stealth farmer program
back when it was highly classified and i
actually couldn't even tell my wife what
i was working on during the daytime it
was that that top secret the original
name for the super soaker was the
drencher we ran into a challenge
regarding the name because another
inventor claimed it so we changed the
name to super soaker just to avoid
having to to deal with that super soaker
is definitely a way better name
when he started lonnie wasn't trying to
create a toy for kids i was working on a
new type of heat pump that would use
water as a working fluid instead of
freon
and i was experimenting with some
nozzles that i machined
and i shot a stream of water across the
bathroom and i thought she's maybe i
should put this hard side stuff aside
and work on something fun like a water
gun
it still works and this brings me back
to a previous point monty johnson is a
super genius scientist
this is his lab
and this is what he's working on now
right now working on advanced maverick
technology my goal is to develop a
battery that will store about three
times the energy of a lithium-ion
battery in comparison the super soaker
might not seem as hard science
but it was still a really really
important invention
[Music]
silly string that bright fun party in an
aerosol can was actually invented by
mistake
believe it or not it was supposed to
help heal your broken bones
[Music]
in 1972 leonard a fish an inventor and
robert p cox a chemist were granted a
u.s patent for a foamable resinous
composition
the two initially set out to create an
aerosol can that could spray an instant
cast on a broken leg or arm and the
invention worked but when it came to
packaging their discovery they tested
500 different types of nozzles through
their tests fish came upon one that
produced a string a string that shot 30
feet across the room inspired they
decided to turn their instant cast into
a toy
after altering the formula to produce a
more colorful less sticky string the
pair set out to market their product
neither of them knew the first thing
about selling toys so they made an
appointment with wamo in california
but the meeting didn't go exactly as
planned
fish and [ __ ] sprayed the string all
over the office including on the person
they were meeting with and
unsurprisingly get out they were asked
to leave the premises just one day later
fish received a telegram from wemo
asking him to send 24 cans for a market
test
turns out that a trace of the silly
string was left on a lampshade in the
office and was later spotted by wemos
owners who themselves demanded a market
test immediately
[Music]
two weeks later guamo signed a contract
to license the product now known as
silly string
[Music]
it starts with a yes or no question does
she have a crush on me will i pass the
test will the mats win the world series
while they may not have always predicted
the truth magic 8 balls are actually
inspired by a real-life clairvoyant
do you want to hear your fortune
in the 1940s mary carter was a popular
medium best known for her mysterious
fortune telling invention it was called
the psychoslate essentially a chalkboard
with a cover when the clients would
visit mary would ask a question to the
spirits
the room would fill with the sound of
scribbling and then just like poof magic
mary would reveal answers from another
world mysteriously written on the
chalkboard
mary's son albert was inspired by his
mother and created his own truth-seeking
device but this time you didn't need a
psychic to tell you your fortune
he put a pair of worded dice inside a
tube filled with molasses each end was
clear so you could read the answers
sound familiar
albert hit the streets he partnered with
a couple local businessmen and opened a
novelty company where they specialized
in the miracle home fortune teller after
he died albert's partners took over and
redesigned the project numerous times
they ended up with a crystal ball like
shape with a die in the middle and a
billiards company took note they needed
a promotional item so they replaced the
crystal ball with the iconic black eight
ball
the promotion was so successful that
they rebranded the magic 8-ball this
time marketing it as a fortune-telling
toy
today kids are still using magic 8-balls
to ask for their fortunes and for that
you can thank mary the clairvoyant
[Music]
strong museum in rochester new york is
also known as the national museum of
play more than half a million objects
are here
my name is chris bench i'm vice
president for collections at the museum
and it's chief curator our collections
are divided by category and here are
some of the people who are responsible
for them
nicholas ricketts is curator of board
games
in our collection
we have around 10 000 board games
and it parallels
essentially american history since the
revolution
when you think in terms of games they
all tend to represent the areas in which
they were created it's a different way
of getting into the mindset of people
who lived 100 years ago
there's michelle parnet dwyer curator of
dolls
in this collection we have more than 15
000 dolls and it spans from the 18th
century to present day
dolls are special because of the way
that we connect with them we
project ourselves our hobbies our
interests our values towards others
when we look at the history of dolls and
how we've played with them it shows that
we connect
to people from the past in ways that we
might not have
expected martin reinhardt head of
pinball and arcade game collections
we have over 250 arcade machines and
over 100 pinball machines in the
collection
pinball
is real you can feel the way the game
plays you can feel the way the game
moves as
you're playing it
it's just in my nature to keep these
machines going they were made to last
five years in a commercial environment
and the fact that we have games that are
30 40 50 60 years old is amazing to me
[Music]
so i'm curator responsible for general
toys things like action figures and
yo-yos this collection has more than 70
000 objects
toys always reflect what's going on in
the world around them when it's economic
boom times construction toys are big
when the us is at war we see all sorts
of military and war toys
the toy collection is a wonderful
example of how times have changed and
people have changed over the
is really years it's an integral part to
who we are as human beings only by
understanding how play has stayed the
same and more importantly changed over
the years can we understand how we've
developed as people and how we've played
over the centuries
[Music]
ah first crushes we all remember them
and if you're a girl who grew up in the
90s your first crush might have been one
of the dream phone guys
oh boy
i think gary he has kind of a nice smile
yeah i'd say matt's probably a jock
this is mike gray the unlikely inventor
of the ultimate 90s tween dating game we
needed a game targeted towards nine year
old girls it was a bunch of guys
that did it but that's okay i know who
it is but i'm not jealous
i said let's do something that's kind of
like clue so it's deduction we're going
to call a bunch of boys because we heard
some boy likes us
so it all started with the phone right
yes
we kind of laughed and we kind of called
this the pink slipper you know in its
day it was an elegant and beautiful
thing i know where he hangs out so how
did they pick the boys of your teenage
dreams we went to a photo house we
didn't know like who these boys were or
anything we just picked ones that we
liked
but that's not the only 90s girls game
mike made he also made the super
successful maul madness but he's pretty
real about his influence as a guy well
if i'm going to make a game about
shopping what i know about shopping you
just go get what you need and get back
to the car
later it was pointed out to me that
that's kind of not the way ladies shop
so it was kind of in a funny way a guy's
game you know
but it was for girls
i say games are togetherness in a box
play a game with people you learn a lot
about them and it shouldn't be about
winning and losing it should be about
being together
[Music]
when the young kids on the street found
out that i was working on star wars i
was like a god to them
those kids are now parents
they've seen the movies throughout the
years
there's always in the back of their mind
like oh wow i remember playing with the
falcon i remember playing with the
x-wing and the tie fighter
[Music]
to understand
that you have a small part of that kind
of bigger world
is is pretty cool
[Music]
my name is mark boudreau
and i've been fortunate enough to work
on star wars toys since 1977.
[Music]
amazing thing about star wars i don't
think it's really ever gone away it's
always been there
vehicles has been sort of what i really
am the most passionate about
tie fighters
a raised speeder
i've always built models built planes
cars so they said hey mark why don't you
go ahead and start working on the
millennium falcon that's like sure why
not
[Music]
the lane falcon is more than just a
machine
it really is a character that helps save
the day it's more than just a hunk of
junk
he wanted to be able to provide an
experience that could extend from the
film
so when you went to go see the movie you
come right back and you're playing with
luke you're playing with han you're
playing with chewie and you're able to
relive everything that you saw on the
film
[Music]
long after i've gone to the forest
wherever that might be
this product will still be there
grandkids from now
will hopefully still be enjoying star
wars and we certainly want to try to do
our small part into making sure that
that continues
[Music]
you